Cheerio!
Sorry, I can't do it.
Can't do the cheerio?
That was part of a script.
Oh.
That was a great
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
Let's try it once more.
Welcome to Client Server
Communications, a course
about the web.
Technically, the web is only
a small part of the internet.
However, it is the only
part of the internet
that people use without
even realizing that what
they're using is the web.
The web is the platform
that you, the web developer,
can use to publish your
ideas to the world.
It is the common language
between your servers
and your clients.
Every time you open a browser,
every time you download an app,
every time you receive a
message on WhatsApp or Facebook,
you're using the web.
More generically,
in that very moment,
a client is communicating
with a server, and vice versa.
But what does that
actually mean?
What's happening when you
navigate to a web site?
How did the phone know that
somebody sent me a message?
What capabilities does the web
have, and more importantly,
what are its limitations?
Hi.
I'm Surma.
I'm an engineer at
Google in London,
and I work with the Chrome team.
In this course, we are
going to understand
what the web actually is, how
we can use it to your advantage,
and how you can avoid mistakes
that will make both your user
experience and security suffer.
Some of this may seem like
[INAUDIBLE] to you, and it is,
but we will also go into the
lesser known parts of HTTP.
To think like an
engineer, you need
to understand both the
semantics that HTTP uses,
as well as the implementation
inside the browser.
We'll use that knowledge to
use browser APIs to the fullest
potential, secure HTTP
against eavesdroppers,
and deploy the web's
newest protocol, HTTP2.
All this knowledge will help
you make informed decisions
for your app and persuade others
when optimizing and securing
their apps.
Hi.
I'm Richard, a course
developer at Udacity
and an experienced
web developer.
While Surma teaches you about
HTTP's request and response
cycle, security, and the
best practices of HTTP2,
I'll be here to
reinforce this knowledge
with examples and quizzes.
Understanding both the
capabilities and limitations
of the medium we work
in on a day to day basis
will help you take the next
important step towards mastery.
By the end of this course,
you will understand literally
every byte that is being sent
from your browser to the server
and back.